jean-françois les rescapés sont donc
arrivés au port ce soir on peut imaginer
un peu de l'état dans lequel ils sont
qu'est ce qui les attend maintenant
écouter un état terrible le patio bien
évidemment ces gens là ont vécu l'enfer
ils ont survécu à l'enfer ils ont vu des
centaines en fait de gens qui se sont
noyés sous leurs yeux qui ont été avalés
par la méditerranée parce qu'ils l'ont
dit il ya entre 700 et 900 personnes qui
prenaient place à bord de ce navire la
donc et ils sont arrivés ici sont prises
en charge par les secours par la croix
rouge notamment il ya de l'aide
psychologique qui leur est aussi offerte
et puis ensuite c'est un long processus
qui débute ce processus là pour demander
le droit d'asile ici en europe c'est
bien rodée ce processus là les italiens
connaissent ça très bien parce qu'on a
c'est la sicile entre autres l'île de
lampedusa on est vraiment ici en
première ligne on accueille des milliers
et des milliers de migrants comme ça
qu'ils partent bien souvent d'afrique du
nord c'est un processus qui est lyon
c'est pas du tout automatique donc ces
gens là sont loin d'être au bout de
leurs peines sauf que ils peuvent
compter sur un formidable élan de
solidarité que l'on sent ici en sicile
que l'on sent un peu partout à travers
l'italie les gens étaient touchés
italiens étaient touchés par ce qu'ils
ont vu et ils veulent vraiment faire un
effort supplémentaire pour accueillir
ces gens là bon et parlons maintenant de
l'enquète parce qu'entre temps on a
ouvert une enquête pour tenter de
remonter cette filière du passeur pour
trouver les responsables
effectivement ces lignes il faut savoir
qu'à bord de ce navire longue de la
garde côtière qui a ramené ces
survivants ici il y avait bien sûr des
sauveteurs il y avait aussi des
enquêteurs italiens qui ont ouvert donc
une enquête criminelle pour essayer de
déterminer d'abord quelles sont les
causes de cet accident là ils ont
interrogé les survivants d'abord pour
déterminer s'il ya certains d'entre eux
qui étaient des responsables de ce
navire là il semble bien que oui
puisqu'il ya deux personnes on apprend
ce soir qu'il ya deux personnes parmi
les survivants qui ont été arrêtés qui
vont être accusés en fait d'avoir mis en
danger la vie des autres parlent d'un
ressortissant libyen et d'un tunisien on
parle clairement de responsabilité
criminelle parce qu'il faut savoir que
d'après les témoignages des survivants
il ya plusieurs centaines de ces de ces
migrants là qu'ils étaient enfermés à
bord des cales du bateau dont vinaver
aucune chance de s'en sortir lorsque le
navire a chaviré mais c'est vraiment
épouvantable
bon il ya la responsabilité criminelle
mais il ya aussi le problème des secours
qui sont nettement insuffisants en mer
jean françois c'est clair céline et
c'est vraiment ce qui préoccupe ici les
italiens plus que le nombre de réfugiés
qui arrivent ici c'est vraiment
l'insuffisance des secours les italiens
demandent à l'union européenne de faire
davantage ils tirent la sonnette
d'alarmé ils disent qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de faire face seule à ce problème
là il semble que l'europe commence à les
entendre les ministres des affaires
étrangères et l'intérieur de l'europe se
sont réunis aujourd'hui sont mis
d'accord sur une série de mesures pour
accroître le nombre de bateaux donner
plus de moyens en fait à cette opération
de secours en mer on va élargir aussi la
zone de recherche donc il semble bien
que l'italie a été entendu tout le monde
semble aujourd'hui d'accord pour tout
faire pour que ne plus revoir pour ne
plus revoir ce genre de drame là à
l'avenir une europe qui tentent de se
mobiliser merci beaucoup jean françois
nous envient revoir